Merry friggin Christmas!
Ah! The kids!
Merry Christmas Eve!
You're just gonna leave?
Where is he?
You said he was going out for a pack of candy
canes.
You mean like those?
Okay. Wake up.
He is not coming back.
We need to change into our regular clothes
and sneak out. Oh, who am I kidding?
My eyes are unforgettable.
I couldn't even hold on to a fake husband.
I always thought you were the tough one to
live with, but maybe I am.
Okay, they've reached the jelly bean moat.
This is a problem. It's a big problem.
All this time, I've been waiting for a guy
to see the true me. And now I'm scared he
will. Oh, my God, they got Blitzen.
What's going to happen to me?
Am I just going to nitpick everyone until
they leave me? Hey, mom.
Found somebody.
That's true. Okay, listen, we really need to
get out of here, but I just want to let you
know that you weren't all bad to live with.
Where's Santa?!
Okay.
Here comes the tree.
Finally.
Here comes more of the tree.
Hey, honey.
Oh! Oh, my gosh, what happened?
Well, uh, someone ran over it, but that's
okay, because we are going to put it back
together. Right now?
It's gonna need a lot of gum.
Oh, thank God. Here comes Phil and the
Butterball.
I have a name.
Huh? I am sorry, but there is no turkey.
There's no turkey. What's the plan, Phil?
Cornish game hens.
If you get real close, they look like
turkeys and everyone gets their own.
Sounds like fun.
Not fun, not fun.
I asked you to pick up a cooked turkey.
The store was out of turkeys.
It was an hour or two express Christmas.
Please just make it work, okay?
Please.
Not even defrosted.
Fine. Claire. You want them defrosted?
Yeah.
Merry freaking Christmas.
Is that my stun gun?
Yep.
And it works great.
Mini Luke.
Knock it off. No one thinks it's funny.
Are you talking to us? Huh?
Hey, as long as everybody's just sitting
around.
Oh, they're gonna do another one.
Ah, thank you, Santa Claus.
That's hilarious.
Hope you're having fun, cause that's about
to end.
Okay, stick to the scripted patter, sweetie.
All right. And a one and a two.
Silent night.
Oh, my God, what was that?
I'm sure it's fine. Here we go again.
Silent night.
That is your daughter screaming.
Lily, are you okay?
The forgotten boy, I heard him.
He's in
there. All right.
Of course he is. Lets get him out.
Huh? Make sure that he doesn't bother.
Oh, God. Oh, God.
Andy. Take off the blazer.
Today was my chance to shed a very unfair
reputation. Claire.
I put two people in the hospital one time,
and now I'm a Christmas ruiner.
Fire! Oh my God, get the extinguisher!
Oh, it's Cam's glitter card.
I knew it! Stand back!
Watch the gifts- Ahh the gifts.
Oh, no.
Honey. It's out.
This must be the one Luke and I use for our
jetpack prototype.
You know, we're being crazy.
There is no perfect moments.
We're just going to walk in there like
adults and tell them.
How do you call yourself Colombian.
After letting that skunk off the hook so
easily, tell me at least that you have one
of his toes in your pocket.
Come on now, Gloria, this is good news.
Disloyalty being rewarded.
Disloyalty. Really, dad?
I caught Gloria interviewing for a job with
another realtor.
What? Chica, how could you?
There she is. The woman that threw herself
out the window to avoid me.
No, dad don't be silly, I fell.
No, no, no.
Honey, I get it. You don't want to come and
work for me. And I think I know why.
Dad. I'm sorry.
No, you don't
want to let me down again.
Like with that whole Ezra Vision fiasco.
What?
Oh, insensitive old white man.
What would Christmas be without one?
We seem to have insensitive people of all
ethnicities.
Was that a shot at me? I've been good.
You can't believe the stuff I haven't said
today.
Cam, what's up with your trip home?
Your parents aren't even there.
Merry Christmas, not happy holidays from
Galveston.
Okay. How are you snooping through my phone?
Oh, you.
That was a false boomerang.
You know what? Forget it.
Forgiven. I just want today to be a special
Christmas. Now, please, everyone sit down.
We'll grab hands, say grace, have a lovely
meal.
Never saw this before.
An angel for my angels.
Love, mom. Oh.
That's beautiful.
It smells like mothballs.
Just like Nana.
Luke.
Thank- Merry Christmas.
Just. Just give it up. Yeah.
He hates us.
Don't beat yourself up.
I do that, like, once a week.
The good news is we never have to come back
here. Watch out.
The tree. Yeah, I can't watch.
Look, I yes, I said.
Look, you told me already I did it, right.
I!
Never look back. Never.
Maybe we can salvage it.
Are you okay, papi?
Yeah.
Good. That's because we had our guardian
angel. Ah a spider!
We have an announcement.
Dylan and I are having a baby.
Are they smiling?
You're pregnant?
Yes. And we're really happy about it.
Why wouldn't you be?
Wow.
Mom.
It's it's a lot to process it once and.
Huh.
Baby? Unbelievable.
Oh congratulations.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, God.
You handled that a lot better than I did back
in the day.
Outside. On the inside.
I'm you.
Can somebody saved my life?
Oh, Cam.
Grab a foot.
Yep. Merry Christmas Eve.
Merry Christmas
Eve. A little, little lower, dad.
Merry Christmas Eve.
Thank you. Thanks for the sweaters.
Oh.
You're welcome. You look beautiful in them,
darling.
Where's mom?
Mom is sinking fast.
Uh oh. She's in the bathtub.
Get it?
They have that claw foot.
Oh, yeah. Hey, pops, here's the tree.
And, uh, there there's the there's the
ornament you sent us.
Right here.
There are the stockings hung by the chimney
by Claire.
Oh, still funny son.
What the hell is that. Is that still funny.
What is that. That looks like a cigarette
burn. Was one of you smoking a cigarette?
No, no.
Which one of you was smoking?
Not me. I have a respiratory.
Obviously it wasn't you.
Now I've got a family of liars and smokers.
Did you shoplift your Christmas presents
too? Haley, keep that ugly sweater on.
Hey, hey.
How's it going?
There are no puppy pounds anywhere.
It's like trying to find a Cabbage Patch Kid
on Christmas Eve, 1983.
Still hurts. Huh?
I had her bed all made.
Okay, well, Lily is going to be devastated.
Call around, get us on some lists.
You have to do something.
I'll figure it out.
How's the fundraiser?
Oh, well, I'm managing, you know, oh bring
the checkbook. You can always tell when
they're gearing up for the big ask.
Fill you full of freebies.
Oh, hey, I gotta go.
Gotta help somebody. Hi.
Classic. Flawlessly executed.
If I had
one- Trying to bring a
smile to you folks.
You're gonna get through this.
Get through what? Don't be
embarrassed. Everyone here is in the same
boat.
We are. Best thing about the hot chocolate?
They let us keep the mug.
I thought it was a charity event for the
needy. Turns out it was a charity event for
the needy.
Look, Santa gave me a puppy, pal.
What?
No. I'm finally
happy.
I'd like a picture for the newsletter.
You could show your mommy.
I don't have a mommy.
You know what? The best thing I did all day
was forgiven you for getting me fired.
Jingle bells, jingle bells.
Jingle all the
way. Oh, what fun it is
to ride in a one horse.
Open one horse open one horse open sleigh.
Hey, jingle all the way.
Hey!
Andrew. Ensemble.
I know it's no accident that you're here on
my street tonight, and I.
I just wanted to say to you all that.
You sound great.
And Merry Christmas.
Wow. Even your apology is off key.
Not cool buddy.
Oh, well, I should, uh, probably scoot.
But.
But what? What about forgiveness?
You were nice.
He was naughty.